clock it's Friday morning good morning
to you good morning to you good to see
you again yes good morning glad to have
you back yeah and we're heading into the
weekend which is always a wonderful
thing so we sat down I said so Heather
what do you got going on this weekend
figure was gonna be a quick response no
it was like a paragraph you have so much
going on this week honestly I just can't
even eight o'clock Miranda Lambert
that's that I've got my eyes set on
Miranda Lambert tonight a lot of folks
have very busy weekends as well there's
a lot going on a lot of food to eat too
uh let's talk about the weather forecast
for the weekend What's it gonna look
like here Sherry sweats good morning
Sharon good morning you guys happy
Friday there's a lot of food to eat
every weekend is it there I love this
place there's so much to do and the
weather is going to be spectacular in
fact we have a little warm-up coming
back for our first weekend of autumn
fall officially arrived yesterday
evening and it is beautiful out there
clear skies light winds and dry air look
at that humidity 14 humidity I woke up
this morning going
I did not drink enough water before I
went to bed last night only 18 is the
dew point temperatures already in the
60s at this early hour 6 29 as the
Sunrise 6 36 is the sunset we're going
to get back into some upper 70s
mid-morning mid 80's by noon lots of
good Sunshine for our first full day of
autumn and we'll be looking for a high
today right back in those low 90s where
we finished summer yesterday we'll look
at the warmer numbers though in your
eight day forecast right now good
morning to Nate Tannenbaum let's get a
look at your drive and here he is
okey-doke happy Finally Friday and the
freeways are in excellent shape a heads
up again about the ongoing work for your
new favorite freeway project the I-15
Tropicana rebuild eventually a complete
rebuilding of the trough in the I-15
starting with a whole bunch of littler
stuff various Lane reductions HOV lane
closures in both directions right now
the Northbound has the far right lane
take it away doesn't appear to be a deal
breaker by any means a museum Legion
Stadium here and the Rio I believe in
the next little while we'll probably see
some endot folks moving those columns
further over to the right shoulder
coming up in our next report we'll check
in on that shutdown of the strip
yesterday I'm pretty sure they're all
done we'll take a look in just a few
minutes John Heather Nate appreciate
that a Serial stabber under arrest here
in the Valley Metro says he was
responsible for multiple stabbing some
deadly over the past week 33-year-old
Christopher Martell is accused of
killing two women and seriously injuring
two others most of these attacks happen
between Flamingo and Harman around UNLV
officers say surveillance video from
nearby businesses led to the arrest the
stabbings of course are not very far
from the UNLV campus which has students
and others living in that area concerned
about their safety University Police say
campus is a safe place
we are well aware of what happens in our
surrounding community and how it might
impact us but generally speaking our
campuses are an island of safety and we
take great pride in providing that
service University Police are now
considering adding more plain clothes
officers to increase surveillance two
people are dead after a house fire up in
Centennial Hills Las Vegas fire and
rescue say a man and woman were killed
in this fire the Heat and the flames in
fact were too intense for firefighters
to enter right away when they got to the
scene and the roof eventually caved in
as neighbors watched by the time I got
there it was already sort of being put
out they had the big uh the the ladder
extended out to the top of the roof
spreading the fire everywhere I mean
spraying water everywhere
certainly a tragedy the cause of the
fire right now is under investigation
every year thousands of Nevada children
are reported missing most of them are
right here in Las Vegas many also
considered runaways who leave home and
then they end up in unsafe situations
our Sasha Loftus talked to a family
searching for their 15 year old daughter
foreign
vanished Autumn and William Trejo are
doing everything they can to bring her
home we're not complete with our
fifteen-year-old Julie Trejo has not
been seen since last Friday and her
parents are worried she's in danger it's
hard for me to walk through the house
and not hear there
so they're now spending all their time
canvassing neighborhoods in North Las
Vegas where anyone could have seen her
this is very very Troublesome we would
like to find Julie Samantha Potts of
local organization missing Justice is
helping with the search
she says cases like Julie's which North
Las Vegas Police has classified as a
runaway aren't uncommon according to
Nevada homeless Alliance our state has
the highest rate of unsheltered
unaccompanied kids in the nation while
about three-quarters of teens who've
left home returned safely Potts says
these situations still deserve time and
attention they are absolutely in danger
because they may have ran away and
linked up with the wrong people as for
Autumn and William they hope their
efforts will encourage anyone who may
know something to help make their family
whole again Las Vegas please bring our
baby home
Sasha Loftus 8 News Now Julie lasting
near Commerce and and if you have any
information about her whereabouts please
call police five minutes past four
conspiracy theorist Alex Jones on the
witness stand again he's being sued in
another Sandy Hook defamation trial
Jones admits he lied when he called the
2012 school massacre a hoax and now he's
trying to limit the financial damages
that he must pay to victims families
they say they've been harassed and
threatened after Jones claimed they were
actors Jones says he's done apologizing
to the families he called the judge a
tyrant and the proceedings a kangaroo
court
so how do I answer why I think
something's a kangaroo court if I'm not
supposed to say why I think it is
certainly a testy experience there and a
separate trial last month Jones was
ordered to pay two Sandy Hook families
50 million dollars in Damages this case
could cost him even more
in New York it is day four of the United
Nations General Assembly and once again
Russia's invasion of Ukraine is very
much on the agenda the U.S is urging
allies in other countries to really put
some pressure on Russia and end this war
here's Bradley Blackburn with more
fearing the prospect of being sent to
the front lines in the war on Ukraine
many Russians are scrambling to flee the
country with traffic backed up at
several border exits the Ukrainian
offensive continues and pushes back the
Russians even while they're trying to
find men find soldiers to put in place
of those that have already been killed
the rush to leave after Russian
President Vladimir Putin's surprise
announcement earlier this week of a
partial military mobilization of 300 000
Reserve troops it's Russia's first
mobilization since World War II the very
International order that we have
gathered here to uphold is being
shredded before our eyes
we cannot
we will not allow President Putin to get
away with it addressing a United Nations
security council meeting Thursday U.S
Secretary of State Anthony blinken laid
out the case against the war and
highlighted Putin's latest threat to use
nuclear weapons President Putin said
that Russia would not hesitate to use
and I quote all weapon systems available
end quote in response to a threat to its
territorial integrity
a threat that is all the more medicine
giving Russians intention to Annex large
swaths of Ukraine in the days ahead
voting began today in referenda in four
russian-controlled areas of Eastern and
Southern Ukraine on weather to become
part of Russia Western Nations have
condemned those votes as a sham and
non-binding officials warned that the
Kremlin might use any Ukrainian effort
to recapture those regions as an attack
on Russian territory Bradley Blackburn
CBS News New York Ukraine and its allies
have already said they will not
recognize the outcome of the vote since
most of the pre-war Ukrainian population
has fled the areas that are in question
congresswoman Liz Cheney was the guest
speaker at last night's Nevada State
Dinner Gala it was hosted by the Vegas
chamber in D.C Cheney who lost the
Republican primary in Wyoming this year
spoke about different topics including
the war in Ukraine and the upcoming
election the gala capped off a busy few
days for the Vegas chamber there in D.C
where they've been pushing for our local
economy in the nation's capital Clark
County has turned over its election poll
worker information to the Republican
National Committee the move comes after
a lawsuit filed by the RNC over the last
presidential election it requested the
data because poll workers can't be just
from one political party under Nevada
law the RNC says that information is
public record as and they need it part
of their as part of their lawsuit
Heather voters can't expect information
on upcoming ballots here in the mail in
the next week the general election
ballot includes three Statewide ballot
questions seeking amendments to the
state constitution Boulder City voters
will have three additional questions and
Henderson voters we'll have one
additional question
we're coming up next some great weekend
events for nature lovers who doesn't
love nature yes we're both Pro nature
we're pro- nature here plus Las Vegas
Raiders looking to put a win on the
board on Sunday we'll hear from Star
receiver Devonte Adams
and training camp opens for the golden
knights how players are hoping this
season will be better than the last one
Sherry we'll have a lot of gold and